howdy rick how's life treating you just  getting by you know  tending to things how's the ox damn good  nice ox oh yeah you know sometimes you  just got too much on your plate you know  i feel like that's you sometimes jim if  you need to get that ox off your plate  like i'm  i'm around well don't you have an ox  yourself my ox is  dirt compared to your rocks like i it's  not even a comparison are you  coveting my ox no that not that nice you  know that's a sin rick i wouldn't do  that i wouldn't uh i simply say it as i  see it well i'll i'll see you around  jeff bye rick take care  i know what you've been up to oh no you  did nothing wrong you just got coveted  by my neighbor how did i come about what  you can get coveted  maybe i should move back to the city but  i've built a home here